perfect good morning everyone how are
you doing how's your day so far okay
coffee helps right my name is olya
garish I work at Microsoft I'm a program
manager on dotnet team and right now I'm
working on Windows desktop and dotnet 5
and right before that I was working on
creating machine learning framework for
dotnet called a mouth net and my
background is in mathematics and
artificial intelligence so that's why
I'm talking about machine learning today
and machine learning became extremely
popular over the last decade right
everyone have heard about machine
learning everyone is interested in it
but my experience from talking to
developers and just looking at surveys
and some stats is that most developers
right now are not yet proficient in
machine learning and not using machinery
in everyday life but rather are in a
very beginning of their journey where
they just have some interest or maybe
start getting to machine learning so I
would be super curious to test it on
this audience I very curious to see
where you guys are if you could raise a
hand who is using machine learning in
your projects in everyday life ok
perfect we have some hands that's
awesome and how many of you have tried
machine learning and maybe which courses
oh ok so your guys basically experts so
if you know something we can skip this
topic I will be asking if you know that
and then I'll just keep material and
building more time for coding on for
questions all right so they're two
different opinions on how developers
should use machine learning right now
because huge interest brought to life
many machine learning frameworks that
implemented existing solutions and they
do a lot of machining work with machine
learning work for us so one opinion is
that machine learning should be easy in
2020 you don't
to implement anything you don't need to
gain a data science degree
you should just leverage the framework
and take the model it spits out embed it
in your application and be done with it
there's also another point of view that
says that when you start doing machine
learning without knowing all the
mathematics behind it that's what you
might end up doing my personal opinion
is that the same balance between the two
is the best solution and of course you
don't need to multiply matrices and
implemental algorithms in your code you
should leverage what exists but also
it's very important to understand the
basics of ml so you can use it in the
most efficient way and that's why today
we will do two things first we will do a
machine learning crash course where I
very quickly cover all the basics of
machine learning how it works main
definitions like what you need to know
one to start actually working with a
mile and look at documentation and not
be scared of all those terms and
algorithms and then we will create a
machine learning model in dotnet so
machine learning crash course artificial
intelligence and machine learning
there's things that we see in our
everyday life when facebook suggests us
to tag a photo of a friend when we work
with our virtual assistants like ok
Google elects and so on uber lyft and
other rideshare providers they use
machine learning heavily they calculate
prices because you might have noticed
that the price for the same distance can
be different depending on the rush-hour
or demands and so on so it all is done
with machine learning when Siri gives us
life advisors or when Amazon says people
who bought this product also were
interested in that and that products
that all is machine learning some other
examples of how you can use machine
learning in your applications would be
predict a sentiment analysis of a review
or detect if a transaction was proud
because if I
is it retention risk or recognize
handwritten text or digits what is
common for all those scenarios ideas
they all are difficult or impossible to
implement using traditional algorithms
right so how would you implement if that
picture is a face or not if you can try
to look at pixels but then there are
different skin colors there are
different close-ups and it's almost
impossible what machine learning does it
creates a function we call it model and
it fits in data data with known answers
and it Tunes this function that process
we call training until that function is
actually able take as input a data a
picture and produce a result that is a
face or that's not a face and they'll
take a closer look at that but for now
there are two kinds of machine learning
models their pre trained or pre built
services and their custom so pre train
it's when machine learning model is
already built trained fine-tuned for you
it's done by providers services and you
simply consume you send that model
questions you immediately received
answers and let me show you one of the
solution that we have it's easier
cognitive services how many of you have
worked with age or cognitive services
okay great then very quickly you
probably have seen the console here you
can create a resource you can choose AI
on machine learning and here all the
variety of things you can do
creating resource sticks sometimes I
already created computer vision and we
have a console where you can plan you
can get a few of those advice so here
API stirs analyze text budget files
describe image detect object and so on
let's try this detect object
I have a picture that is a butterfly and
it's called monarch butterfly I didn't
know that when I saw a monarch I was
expecting to see the Queen but I'm gonna
copy URL to that file and I will insert
it here and sent so that's how my
request looks like and this is my
response
so here oh I'm sorry here you can see
the object is monarch butterfly so that
AI almost has a PhD in biology and I
didn't know that it also provides you
coordinates for that butterfly so it
dries a rectangle around the butterfly
there is another service another API
that describes the image for you and
here for example we can take this
picture because I just came back from
vacation and if I insert the link to
that one
and son okay here you can see that we
have a bunch of talks outdoor water boat
and a text a group of people on a boat
in the water so pretty good right those
are pre-built services for you basically
takes no effort
they're usually paid so if you they work
for you then perfect just use them and
behavior but there are cases when
pre-built services would not work for
your particular case and that is why
that's because those services are
generalized tasks that are built on like
available to everyone data if you have a
very narrow domain area you can face the
issue like Ultima straight now for
example let's imagine we have a store of
vacuum cleaners right and we're gonna
use Azure cognitive services to see how
good our reviews for my vacuums right
and when we have a review this is a
great vacuum cleaner everything is great
the service stalls it's a very positive
review so everyone is happy but then if
I stand the review this vacuum cleaner
sucks so much dirt the result will be
negative because sucks usually means
sucks and for my particular domain area
I will need to use mine data to train
the model to in order to get the results
that are valid for my case and in this
case you will need to build a custom
machine learning you can do that if you
have everyplace repetitive decision or a
process you solution lacks explicit
definition or otherwise you would just
program at the normal way and you have a
lot of historic data data is very
important because machine learning
algorithms existed sixty years ago but
they didn't took off back then because
we didn't have computers that
able to process and accumulate enough
data now when computer is good better in
the last twenty ten years machine
learning bloomed so if you're gonna do
custom machine learning let's get
familiar with some terms and concepts of
machine learning there are three ways of
machine learning it's supervised
unsupervised and risk
reinforcement learning supervised or
it's also called learning with a tutor
that's when for our data with no right
answers so for example we have a
forecast of weather for the past year or
we have a prices we have a number of
sales that we want to predict we know
that for previous cases then we train
our model we show the right results and
we configure the model we tell her every
time we tell it every time that was
right that was wrong how far you were
from the right answer there is also
unsupervised learning or learning
without tutor where we don't have
answers for our data and in that way we
just organize the data in the way that
we can get meaningful insights on it and
there's also reinforcement learning
that's when we're getting a constant
feedback from the system about our well
being like how well we do great example
would be games where we are interacting
with the environment and we're getting
immediate feedback on our actions so for
example we went left we ate a berry our
well-being improved we went right we
someone ate us our well-being got less
great so that is reinforcement learning
and there are different machine learning
tasks those three are most popular and
we have more on that link I will have
all links at the end so you don't need
to try to capture it right now but I'll
show you so first classification that's
when we want to answer to a question is
this a or b or is it a
or see if we have two possible options
it's binary classification if they're
three or more its multi-class
classification regression that's when
we're finding an answer how much or how
many so it's quite a quantitative
characteristic that would be how hard
the weather will be how many sales will
I make how long do I have to wait what
is the price and so on and there is also
clustering clustering is when we want to
organize our data in certain clusters so
we can get insights and grant example
here would be targeted audience of our
like clients for example to whom we
should show a commercial over bikes to
whom we should show commercial of some
home goods or another example can be
news website with news and we want to
categorize news by topic these are
articles related to sports these are
articles related to politics that would
be clustering so if we remember
supervised and unsupervised learning
classification and regression would be
supervised learning we know answers for
this one clustering is unsupervised
learning we don't know to which cluster
it belongs we just want to organize our
data to work with it more efficient and
if I go on that link I'll show you the
documentation that you can look and
learn for it further yeah it's not virus
so here we just talked about binary
classification multi-class
classification regression clustering
there's anomaly detection where you can
read what it is see examples of it what
algorithms does machine learning has in
this particular case a mall that not to
solve that problem
with our inputs and outputs and also
ranking recommendation forecasting and
so on
so how much in learnin works I like to
learn on jokes I'll read this one for
you so tech interview interviewer what
is your biggest strengths
I mean I'm expert in machine learning
interviewer what is 9+10 it's three
not even close it's 19 okay it's 16 no
it's still 19 it's 18 no 19 its 19
you're high now why it is funny because
when my dad saw it he said like that's
nonsense
it's funny because that's exactly how
machine learning learns like first we're
asking a question 9 + 10 and it gives
the first answer it can come up with 3
and we're showing the right result like
it's 19 it calculates the difference
okay model is not perfect we need to
retrain the model we retrain the model
we get another result 16 compare it to
19 still better but still not ideal now
we know the direction we were trained
the model again and we keep training it
until we get the decent result same
thing we can write in a language close
to mathematics where Y was a hat is a
function of X Y was hat it's our
prediction and it will be some function
of our data X then we create a cost
function which is a difference between
our predicted result and actual result
that we know and we're trying to
minimize that cost function and there
are different algorithms mathematic
algorithms how you can minimize there
are also different ways of how you can
determine the distance here it's just
absolute value but it also can be our
square root min root square and so on in
other words to show what I just talked
about say we have some data and first
and we're trying to approximate it with
some function in this case it will be
linear function we just say thumb and
you calculate how
good we did and we see that we didn't do
very well so we try to come up with
something else okay how good we did well
better but not ideal then how about this
okay perfect
that was a good one our model can be
under fitted it can have a good fit
robust and it can be overheated under
theater that's when we're too far from
the data and prediction is not very well
over fitted that's when we predict every
every input of our data and I would
normally ask what do you think is the
best but kind of good fit gives it away
so I have a question why good fit is
better than overheated why do you think
like why overfitting is bad because I
yeah yes exactly so it will give us a
hundred percent on our test data but
when we go to real-life and we see
different data our model will be too
fine-tuned for our particular test data
so that is the best explanation of
overfitting that I've ever seen and how
do we create machine learning model
first we build our model then we train
it then we evaluate conclude how good or
bad it is if it's good we go ahead and
use it in our application if we are not
happy with results we go back to build
we rebuild it again we train again
evaluate it continue until you're happy
with results on the build to be like
main steps we need to upload our data
that we want to train our model on we
need to prepare this data and that
usually means if you have text you need
to record it in a new Murray in a vector
of numerics so algorithm can understand
it if you have a picture you need to
translate it into numbers if you have
some missing data you need to define
what do you want to do when like some
well
is mistis it will be now and it can
break your model and there are many
other things that data scientists have
to do to get the good data then you need
to choose algorithms there are many
different algorithms and I have a link
that I will show you at the end once we
build the model training that's when we
just train the model according to you
chosen algorithm and on the evaluation
stage we calculate different metrics
metrics are different for each amount
ask for regression classification and so
on they have documentation on that when
you're happy with results you're
consuming the model and now let's get to
the code fits right model and see how
all those stages work in real life
so before we start coding I'm gonna use
a molded net for my custom model I'm all
dotnet it's a framework that allows you
to consume existing models but as well
writing your own models and it's very
young product we released G a version
last year but it's based on internal
product that we have been using for many
many years at Microsoft we used it for
Asia or his Windows hello sequel
services and so on so that was a product
written by our data scientists and few
years ago we realized that you probably
should make it available to everyone
else so we predict eyes it brought it to
open sourced and released and that
framework is extensible it have it has
integration with tensorflow onyx and
inferred and dotnet which means that you
if you have a data scientist that prefer
to create their models in tensorflow or
in any machine learning framework that
supports onyx that's universal neural
network format they can write their
models there then they can you can
import the models in
Amahl dotnet and us developer can stay
in the.net system you don't need to
write the glue code between Python and
dotnet it's cross-platform it supports
the both dotnet core and dotnet
framework it's free obviously and it has
great tooling about tooling I would like
to talk a little more before another
joke you know principle Pareto principle
of principle
in data science 80% of the time is spent
on preparing the data and 20% of the
time is spent on complaining about the
need to prepare the data that's true
because if you don't have good data then
the quality of your model will not be
great but luckily frameworks can do a
lot of work for you and in a mout net we
have Auto ml and model builder all time
well it's a set of api's that kind of
simulate a data scientist for you so
they make all the decisions not all they
help you to make decisions and to find
the best parameters best algorithms and
best strategy and model builder it's a
UI that is using optimal api so there
are two approaches depending on what you
prefer you can go code first and use
ultima api's or you can use extension
and Visual Studio what automail does so
let's look at example let's say we're
writing a taxi application and we want
to generate the price so we want to
predict how much the taxi fare should
cost given some impulse and what
normally data scientists would do they
would define which features are
important for our tasks so there's
distance trip time car time probably the
color of the car is not important but
distance and time is very important then
we need to pick algorithms and their
plane like a lot of algorithms I don't
know which
we'll work the bus you have some general
understanding and God feel and
experience but you need to try few to
find the best for your particular case
and they're also parameters for each
algorithm but you can pick to fine-tune
your model so what data scientist does
it big features it picks algorithm picks
parameters trains a model and on the
first attempt let's say we have a model
that is successful in only 30 percent of
the cases what we do we go back and we
do the process again so we pick
different features different algorithm
and again the model that has a 50%
success and then we repeat and we spend
quite some time until we get something
that has a good precision what automail
does it does exactly that but it does
that all behind the scenes so it italic
intelligently tests multiple models and
gives you the optimized model the one
that is best for your data and your
particular case so with that let's go
ahead and see how it works I'm gonna
open visual studio and to show you what
machine amounted nag does I'm gonna just
start a blank project so I have not
written any code there's nothing that I
prepare I take creating a new project
console dotnet core because you guys
should use that with core it will have
an a Picasso up 17 because I don't have
imagination
looks like my computer is tired alright
so I already installed visuals to the
extension model builder so now I can
just and shall I apologize but let me
start the tool so I can zoom in into my
code I forgot to do that before have any
of you guys used mouth net already okay
great awesome okay
perfect now we all can see so here I
have I can right click on my project go
add and I have machine learning so I'm
gonna click machine learning and let's
remember those stages when we build
train evaluate code that's very similar
here so first we need to pick a scenario
and our problem is to predict taxi fare
so it's going to be predict price and
it's going to be regression then I can
specify a file or sequel server in my
case it's a file I will use a CSV file
train and here it gives you a preview of
the data so I have a few columns for my
historic data its vendor ID rate code
like depending on is it rush hour is it
popular destination passenger count trip
time in seconds trip distance payment
type its cash or credit card and fair
amount in dollars so that's my data I
have nineteen nine thousand entries and
I need to specify column to predict or
label that's the one the question we are
looking the answer we want to find the
answer for it in our case is going to be
fair amount then we can select some
columns or but I'm gonna let out a
amount decide everything for me I select
all I go to the next step then train
here you can specify the time in seconds
and if you are training for production
give it more time but usually there is a
link column should I train for here you
can see if you have a file less than 10
megabytes 10 seconds if it is enough my
file is 3 megabytes so it will be more
than enough for us and
start trainin you can see the process
here and we also have output where we
tell the outer mouth starts picking
algorithms and it calculates the matrix
for them and then okay
finalizing model best quality best
algorithm okay great so it did a few
cases and then defined which one is the
best which one gave best results
now you can on the page evaluate you can
see that overall our square is 0.93 so a
little about those metrics because I
have a regression of the most important
metric according to many data scientists
is R square R square is the close is to
1 the better and there are other metrics
like absolute loss square loss RMS loss
and so on you can read about them in the
documentation but basically you're
trying to find the model that has the
best results on those metrics in our
case it's a fast regression and that's
the model that outer most suggest for us
to use and it already has a small UI
where we can test the model so it took
the first line of my data inserted
values here and I can click predict and
it predicts some amount now we can go to
code click at projects and here I see
two projects were added into my
application one is the name of my
project mo dot console and another ml
dot model let's take a closer look at
them so in model I have model input
that's a class of my vendor ID rate code
questions radius so that's my data
automatically generated the data for me
it parsed it in the class I have model
output where I have a score so the score
is our prediction in our case it's fair
amount how much money which is the trip
cost we have a code that consumes model
and this is what you will be using in
your application and you can actually
just use just call this method but what
it does it creates a mouth context and
we take the path to our model this is
the model that machine-learning created
it's a zip file it's a format of a model
net that's where our train model is
stored we upload the model in our
machine learning context a mal context
model load then we create prediction
engine based on model input and model
output and the model and then on
prediction engine we just call predict
and send the data that we want to find
the answer for and in the other project
ml console we have first this one we'll
just test so we create single data
sample as basically take one line from
our data we call consume model predict
and the sample data and output the
result and that's there's also a model
builder class and that's where the
training happens so what we do here how
pass we create a mouth context we create
a model we're creating a model by
calling a mouth context data load from
file we upload our data specify some
parameters then we call built Train
pipeline
we're on a Mel context we so that's
where it gets a little bit harder but
luckily it generates all the code for
you so you can first see how it is done
and then kind of figure out how it's
supposed to be what we do here we are
agent to our machine learning context we
are adding transformations that is our
data preparation and remember we have
some strings and some digits let me go
back to my data so some of those are
strings for Strings we need to transform
them into numerical actors so what we do
here we use one hot encoding that's the
transformation of a string into vector
we transform vendor ID and and payment
type then we are appending all numeric
vectors that is a transform concatenate
and so as a result data processing
pipeline that's basically we consumed
all the data in the way that machine
learning model understands then we are
creating the trainer trainer its
algorithm plus the task so we have
different algorithms they can be applied
for a different task for example like
first three we can use it for different
machine learning tasks and this is the
first three for regression trainer is a
first three regression here we choose
first three we specify which one is our
label which one we want to predict
results for and the rest our input data
they are called features upend the
pipeline return training pipeline and
[Music]
so they built pipeline then we evaluate
the model for evaluation of our model we
use amount context training data view
and training pipeline training pipeline
that we created before so they actually
first composed we haven't run the
training yet we just composed the model
we created evaluation and only then we
call train model where all the training
and evaluation happens and another thing
for evaluation let's go here we're using
a concept of cross-validation do you
guys know what Chris validation is okay
so usually how we train when we're
building our model we use data right and
we want to make sure that our model will
work for not only the data that we have
but the data in real world too in order
to do so we need to evaluate the model
and conclude that okay that model
actually works not only our on our test
data but in general how can we do that
if we will use same data that we used
for training if we will use that for
evaluation that won't give us any result
right because it will be the data that
we trained our model on usually you
should have two separate sources of data
one is training one is evaluation if you
don't have them separately you can use
cross-validation and Chris validation
the framework kind of does that
separation for you and what it does it
divides your data into various chunks
and then it hides one and it says okay
train the model on everything else and
now evaluated on that one that they
didn't show you before okay now hide
this one and train on everything else
and evaluate on that one and it repeats
it by default five times and then it
gets the aggregated result so that is
cross validation and that's what we're
doing here
again luckily this old code is generated
for you so you don't need to come up
with it you can just look how it's
implemented and then if you want to
optimize that code you can use this one
as a base alright and let's go back to
our model builder so here as well we
have very detailed instructions on what
to do once we pressed generate code it's
added to projects that we just looked at
and I know it looked a bit scary but
instructions here are super easy one run
can so up dot console up let's do that
you're gonna set this as a start project
and run it
all right so what happened here
it trained the model so it did
everything behind the scene it saved the
model in two zip file then it took the
first line of my data and it run the
model on that data and gave us results
so EXO fair amount is eight it predicted
it at 7.8 impressive grade but again I
don't tend to trust it because that data
participated in training right then
number two add input data and we're
going up number two a delusion I'm going
to just go to that I'll set my initial
project to the start project now and I'm
going to end the student how interesting
okay how about
okay three and number three you're gonna
add those lines so what we do here we
create a new model input right now it's
empty and then we call consume model dot
predict that's a class that we got
generated the one that uploads the model
creates a mountain text uploads the
model and cold predicts and returns as a
result that let me add input let me
print so what we're gonna do now we will
add the data and we will call our
consume model dot predict and then we
will print out actual price from the
data and the price that we predicted so
I have a different data here not here
but here this is what I was using for
training taxi fare train and this is a
completely different file it has 1,000
entries let's see so that data my model
have never seen before and let's pick a
line from 1 to 1000 I'll enter the data
and we'll see how the model works so in
your number 72 sounds great
72 I thought it's gonna be for you to I
kind of tested that one already
okay so vendor ID CMT then one one time
seven seven eight distance three point
four it's a credit card and this is this
was the price actual price $13 all right
let's see I'm always so excited I never
know what's gonna happen once one
service oh okay
look at this that's amazing
13 and predicted to thirteen point zero
six nine right yay
[Applause]
of course when you train it's important
to have enough data when when I was
running this model I just remember it I
was pregnant for some conference on the
plane and I was trained in the model
that would predict the sentiment
analysis so it was predict is that
phrase positive or negative and I didn't
have enough time my computer was about
to die so I took a very small amount of
data and you know I trained the
depressed model
it was very biased to work negative it
wasn't happy almost all the time so then
I had to retrain it and once I added
like ten times more data the mood
elevated alright
[Music]
so that's all I have for today I have
some links that you can go ahead and
check out it's we have getting started
for a modded net we have a lot of
samples that you can see how it works
and create your models based on those we
have documentation and since it's open
source it's in our github repository you
are very welcome to give us feedback
report issues participate actually
contribute with us we have a lot of open
source community contributors so that is
a project that we are doing in the open
with you guys and in at the bottom I
have links to those all ml tasks
algorithms and metrics that you can go
ahead and check so thank you so much I'm
happy to answer any questions if you
have it's my favorite questions alright
if you have questions you're welcome to
come up here